hi there steve kaufman here again
i have my blog the linguist on language
and of course the website link lingq.com
and today i want to talk about something
that has been on my mind and it has to
do with the importance of good language
content
content is king in language learning
it comes to mind because
uh of some discussions we've had on our
forum at link and elsewhere or even on
my blog
for example people studying portuguese
they say um i only want european
portuguese or i only want brazilian
portuguese and someone said they were
studying using pimsleur for chinese but
it seems to them that the chinese in
pimsleur is not the way people speak in
the street
and
of course i say if i remember my own
learning like it doesn't matter
what's most important is that the
content somehow be interesting because
when you're starting out in the language
it's very hard for me at the beginning
to tell the difference between a
portuguese
uh
someone from portugal and someone from
brazil i'm very happy if i can see one
but i'm not entirely sure what's more
important is that the content be
interesting
and of course i see you know language
learning content of sort of as being in
two stages you have the beginning the
beginner content which is the asimil and
the teach yourself or any kind of
beginner content
uh
which is necessarily simplified and not
so interesting
and then you have
most of the time that you spend on
languages and language learning which
should be with authentic interesting
content that you chose because you find
it interesting
that beginner period the best kind of
language learning content
is interesting stories and
russian asimil for example is much
better than say teach yourself they have
no english on their recordings and the
stories are kind of funny for a while
uh but the korean assimil was hopeless i
bought it too and i didn't use it
because it was it was just too boring
um
a lot of the sort of beginner texts they
start with phrases
uh or they um
uh you know disjointed phrases to
illustrate a point of grammar or
something or phrases telling you what to
say at the post office the train station
and so forth to me that's wrong that
comes later first you have to build up
an overall level of familiarity with the
language vocabulary and so forth then
you can go back and and deal with
certain
phrase patterns and hopefully they would
you know give you a concentrated dose of
this type of situation that type of
situation and that can include then
uh wording that you might use
um in this you know in the barber shop
in the post office and so forth but
until you have built up this general
familiarity with the language all of
these sort of specialized targeted types
of scenarios or or or phrases
are very difficult to digest in my
opinion and i'm going to talk about what
works for me you can come on here and
say everything you want criticizing me
and saying i'm wrong i don't mind
happy to have all the different
points of view i won't block anyone
anyone as long as they don't swear at me
but this is my feeling when i want to
start when i start the ideal is is a
story a detective story a historical
story a love story anything that has a
little bit of interest to it that goes
from sort of episode to episode 30
seconds long relatively simple language
and the sooner you get off that the
better another good example was what my
uh brazilian tutor prepared a little
diary of her and her kids and they went
to the zoo and stuff like that
sample stuff prepared using deliberately
using simple language doesn't have to be
too slow but it shouldn't be too fast
and everything you listen to it many
times that's the beginner content but as
soon as you possibly can get out of that
and get into real content interesting
content now some people think that the
content has to be graded graded readers
gradually more and more difficult i
don't believe that at all i think
there's two kinds of reading and
listening there is the simple stuff
which might be graded readers or you
might be reviewing uh simple stuff that
you did before and that's what i would
almost call the aerobic part that's
building up your general you know
aerobic capacity your fluency in the
language but you also need to do the
heavy lifting go into stuff where
there's a lot of unknown words where but
you're driven because you're interested
and that's what i did very early on in
russian where i was reading tolstoy and
and on link i was looking up every
second or third word it was but i had
the audio book so i could fight my way
through the chapter and listen to it
read it again listen to it and i sort of
alternated the easy stuff with the
difficult stuff i think you need to do
both it's good for the brain in my
opinion now
um i was gonna also on on this whole
portuguese brazil versus portugal
i listen to both it doesn't matter to me
i'm trying to build up my
you know ability to understand the
language but if you have some excellent
content
uh let's say that i'm more interested in
european portuguese because i'm going
off to portugal on a holiday but uh
there's a person called ruben alves
and i'll put the name in uh somewhere in
the in the comments here who is a
brazilian educator and he has put out
fabulous audio lectures
and i found the text on the internet
which i was able to import into link i
mean he's tremendous
and i'm going to deny myself listening
to him because i'm focused on european
portuguese it doesn't matter what
matters is how interesting is the
content if there were an expert say in
english on a subject that you were very
interested in
and that person spoke with an australian
accent
i mean i think you would be foolish not
to listen to him
uh if you were interested in that
subject because you'll build up a lot of
vocabulary it's not going to change how
you speak because the bulk of your
listening is probably going to still be
from whatever accent you found the most
you know attractive or interesting or or
useful for you
uh so uh interest in in the content is
so key the other thing and and here it's
a pity that i i should have some quotes
from ruben alves but he one of the
things he said was
nothing destroys the pleasure of reading
as much as having to answer questions
about
what was in what you read why someone
did something analyzing the text any of
those things just destroy the pleasure
of reading and they do it all the time
they do it in schools they do it in
literary literary programs and they do
it in language learning for example here
is one of the best
um sort of sources of good content that
i found
after about a year or so into uh into my
russian i happen to find it while i was
in tucson of all places in their
university bookstore advanced russian
through history sounds great it's got
however many lectures many lectures 35
mini-lectures taking you from the
beginning of russian history right
through to modern times
great
they make a point of saying
that the text is different
from the audio why would they possibly
do that they think that has some
pedagogical value so you you read this
text but then they have another little
mini lecture about this text which in
fact is not the same as the text that's
in the book
and then they have
for the teachers
they have here
about the learning tasks
they have a total of 25 tasks
pre-reading tasks complete before
reading the text
pre-reading tasks read and reflect
before reading the text
reading text
tasks complete upon successive
re-readings of the text
and then post reading tasks
and and so you know
stuff like uh locate important places on
the map and explain
why these places are important generally
i mean all kinds of stuff that would
just destroy for me
any interest i would have
in these texts to me i just want to read
them
ideally listen to the same
uh as the text and then move on to the
next one and out of a book like this i
mean if we had this at link and i wrote
them and said can we put this on link i
mean i would glean lots of words
relevant to history they said no anyway
that's one example i mean the other
the other um
end of the spectrum was this uh korean
book where
lots of useless grammatical explanations
and very little very little text so
content
if you are forced and driven by your
interest in the content this has been my
experience
uh you know with with check i mean i've
been at it now for six months i don't
know how many hours a day i put in maybe
one on average one why don't i have two
i don't know
so let's say that's 180
days or hours or 200 hours i don't know
i can read the newspaper depending on
the subject of course if it's on
economics or world politics i can read
it
i have lots of words
now i'm starting to speak
uh but i'm driven like i'm driven i
can't go back to the easy stuff because
i'm driven by my interest what's
happening in the czech republic what's
happening what happened in tech history
or i'm listening to the good soldier
shriek which takes me back to you know
the early 20th century and and so forth
and so on so
interest content give people things that
are interesting to listen to and read
and if you can listen and read you will
learn to speak lots of people say well
you know uh
like i have often and talking to chinese
people they'll tell you chinese learners
that we have your immigrants they'll say
oh you know we chinese we all read well
but we can't speak because we don't
speak in class in china and stuff like
that so then i say well how many of you
actually enjoy reading a novel well not
very many you know in a room of a
hundred maybe one
so when i say that you have really
progressed in terms of your reading that
means you can listen to an book listen
to the radio read and understand
and and one other thing about about
listening course it doesn't help to
listen to stuff you don't understand
that's just noise
and that's why you have to have a
deliberate program which is what i'm
doing with my check
of whatever i listen to
i want the text because if i just listen
to it without the text i miss too much
and gradually and gradually you build up
that familiar familiarity with the
language that then enables you to focus
on other things and those other things
might be might be the grammar you can
get yourself a little grammar book you
know or you can find so much stuff on
the internet if i
if i google
uh conjugate check verbs i get the whole
picture
uh so i don't even need to buy a book
for that but but those are the details
that you go back and fill in afterwards
but the big the big factor to me is is
content language learning should be
content driven how do we get people in
touch with things that are of interest
to them that they can more or less
understand how do we help them to
understand by giving them access to
glossaries by having a system like link
providing audio and text
and let them choose things that are of
interest to them that's what the main
that's the main thing and i should say
that
i'm confirmed in that opinion by the
discussion that i had with with luca
who is a wonderful polyglot from raw who
now lives in paris
and he is absolutely absolutely he
speaks extremely well
uh
in i think we spoke together in nine
languages and i'm going to put it up by
the way
here on my youtube channel unfortunately
the webcam wasn't working so we're gonna
put up two pictures and we're gonna run
this discussion we had in english and
spanish and french and german and
chinese and russian and italian and
swedish
uh but he's the same way
content
get the language in you interesting
content
input
key
um
you know i should plan for these things
but i i had a bunch of other stuff i
wanted to say but i can't remember
but content is
king oh yeah i just wanted to add that
some of the good polyglots that you'll
find on on youtube in the blogosphere or
whatever like lucca like moses like
richard i mean they all have
their little tricks for moving from
input to
output and many of them are very
valuable and you should look up what
lucas says you should look up what moses
says
uh you know i don't know what richard
says on sort of moving to output
in my own case
to me it's just a natural transition at
a certain point i feel i'm ready to talk
i've started now talking in check with
yarda yaroslav our member at link and
maybe the next time i talk with them
i'll uh
i'll record it and put it up here so you
can hear me bumble and stumble
in check
and i just keep stumbling and bumbling
until i get better that's all it is
that's all it takes thanks for listening
bye for now